Let me see.
There we go.
Okay, I don't see the Facebook comments for some reason,
but Jason, Aaron, can you kind of check that out
as we have questions, comments come in?
Can you let me know?
Yeah, for sure.
I will say that one comment I saw on the teaser post you did
that Heather mentioned that she's excited for this live
because this is one of the bigger things
that she sees as a roadblock now for her
is qualifying business owners.
Yeah.
So let's do this.
And by the way, I'm gonna give,
I'm gonna give Aaron, I'm gonna give you co-host
if you're not already because in case my internet,
sometimes it's shaky here, I don't know why.
So let's, I wanna say a few things
and then I'm gonna have Porter,
I'll ask Porter a couple of questions, you as well,
and then we'll go into some Q&A stuff, okay?
Does that sound good, Aaron?
You can hear me though, right?
Yeah, sounds good.
Beautiful, all right, so what I learned
and I'm gonna kind of go back to when I first started,
I remember back in 2016, first deal, towing deal,
of course you guys have probably heard the story,
I did everything wrong, I got lucky,
I picked the right area on accident,
the niche wasn't the greatest, but I still got the deal.
And I remember that that client was the biggest pain
in the butt of anything.
Now, yes, it was a $600 deal, yes, it was my first deal,
yes, I was excited about that more
than probably any other deal that I got,
but I had to work so much for that deal to get paid,
it was unbelievable.
And so I want you guys to know that when you get
that first deal, Porter, I know you've dealt with this,
Aaron, I'm sure you've dealt with this,
it happens, you're excited, you wanna get that deal,
that first person that talks to you,
that says they'll take your leads,
you kind of throw yourselves at them
because you're like, oh my gosh, this is actually working,
somebody's interested, and it takes you going down the road
and having the deal go sideways,
having the business owner not pay you,
having the business owner not be able to close deals.
The worst though is sending the leads,
the business owners, three, four, five leads,
and then getting ghosted because all they wanted
was freebies, right?
There's all these variables.
So guys, I've said this a few times before
and I want you guys to remember this,
just because you can get money from a person,
just because you can close a deal,
just because somebody will say yes,
does not mean that you should agree to it, okay?
It's the same thing in the free Facebook group,
I tell people all the time, and in this group as well,
just because somebody is willing to give you advice
does not mean that you should take it, okay?
Just because someone's willing to pay you
just does not mean that you should take it.
This is something that I live by,
this is including in this group,
there are people that we have gotten on the phone with,
they have wanted to join this group,
they're interested in starting a business,
and we can literally tell they are probably
not gonna finish paying the tuition,
they're gonna be a complete problem,
way more questions than, you know,
they're gonna take more than they're gonna give,
and sometimes it's just not worth it.
So, we wanna talk about qualifying,
and guys, I know that a lot of times,
again, during those first few deals,
it's almost like you're willing to do anything,
it's like, well, at least it's money, right?
That's not true, okay?
My first deal I got, this guy named,
what was his, I don't even remember his name,
but anyway, he was a towing guy,
I closed the deal in person,
and guys, I fought like crazy to get this money every month,
and eventually, it was just not worth it
after some period of time,
and I'm gonna contrast that,
I got a deal with a company back in 2019,
was it 2019 or 2018?
One of those years, I think it might've been 2019,
and then it bled into 2020,
this client, I sent them literally one lead,
they escalated me to the marketing director,
it was a huge company that owned another company,
and I got to the top of the company,
and guys, there was a month or two in there
that they cut me a check for $30,000,
just how big this client got,
and the most amazing part is,
this was the most low maintenance of all the clients.
Can you guys hear me still?
Okay, it's like, it sounds funny,
but usually, the bigger the client,
the easier they are to maintain, okay?
Francesca just landed us a deal for $7,500 per month,
I have not communicated with that business.
Personally, I have not communicated with that business,
I'm not interested in communicating that business.
They are low maintenance, yes, we check in once a week,
but it's worth it, 7,500 bucks a month,
so anyway, let's talk about qualifying.
Porter, I know for you, you landed a few deals,
you got excited, and you were snagging deals,
and I think you were kind of just working with anybody,
because you were just excited,
and then you ended up losing two or three of those deals,
so what did you learn throughout that process?
Dude, it was all, I was calling the wrong people,
first of all, even though I know I know
what I should be doing, I still wanna, I get lazy,
I'm like, oh, I've called everyone on my list,
I don't wanna go write another list,
so I start calling people on Facebook,
I start calling people that aren't running ads,
and I don't know why I thought that I could be the one
to just make those sales, but I'm not, and they're cheap,
everyone that's not doing that is not gonna pay
for the service, so I was calling the wrong people,
and I really don't think, the first two deals that I landed,
I was asking the right questions,
I was bringing up the objections before,
I was talking about the contract,
I was talking about how the deal would look
before I got on the call,
and there was just some things that I just was muffled,
I was just like, oh, I did that, but he already knows,
but he doesn't, you have to bring it up,
you have to ask him, and so those were some things
that I have caught myself, and even just my energy of,
being excited about the business model,
I was definitely a little bit under the weather,
I wasn't as excited, I was probably making it seem
like he wasn't gonna get very many leads,
I was trying to downplay it too much,
so there were some things I didn't do,
but I do think the questions that you ask
are very important, and if they say,
me and Aaron talked about this,
but if they say yes, yes, yes, you should be worried,
because most of the time, there's gonna be a few questions
that come up beforehand, I mean, occasionally,
you'll get one that's like, hey, that all makes sense,
let's work together, but most of the time,
the ones that are actually serious about it
have genuine questions from the beginning,
and they're asking you, and those are the ones
that are gonna stick with you longer.
If it sounds too good to be true, it usually is,
that's what I've learned, okay?
Another principle that I've learned, guys, is,
so I wanna come back to this port to remind me,
I wanna come back to talking to people
that are already paying for ads,
so don't let me forget that, but I wanna mention something,
guys, this is the same thing that I learned
doing door-to-door sales, is if I was on the door,
and so I looked at the sale as two parts,
the door approach and the inside the house and the clothes,
now, granted, there was actually three parts,
there was the door approach, the presentation,
and the clothes, so let's say there's three parts.
What I learned, guys, is that if it was easy for me
to get in the house, no objections, whatever, boom,
they was like, yep, come in,
I was gonna be up for a tough close.
If the door approach was tough, and I had to overcome
one or two objections before they let me in the house,
there was a good chance I was gonna get that deal,
and so back to that, I bet you every single person
out here that's talked to, made at least 50 calls,
we've all dealt with a business owner,
like Porter's talking about, yeah, yeah, yeah,
that sounds good, sounds good, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
and you're just like, yep, and it's like,
it can't be that easy, it's not that easy.
If it's too good to be true, it probably is, okay?
If it sounds too good to be true, it probably is,
so back to what Porter was talking about, guys,
in the training, we talk about this,
in the training, we talk about when you build your list,
why not make it half as easy, twice as easy, half as hard?
Why try to, if you're calling just any random Joe,
you are having to sell them on the idea of paying for leads,
paying for marketing, and on you, right?
If you are selling to people
who are already paying for leads,
you only have to sell them on you.
You don't have to sell them
on why they should be paying for it.
So it is, even if it takes longer to find an area
with business owners that are already paying,
it's a much easier, more logical, quicker sale,
because all you're doing is saying,
look, you've already tried Home Advisor, dude,
if it's not working,
what makes you think it's gonna change?
Why don't you try this with me, right?
They're already in the mindset of the,
hey, I gotta spend money to make money.
It doesn't even mean you need to take the money
from the Home Advisor budget necessarily,
but there's somebody that's willing to spend money, okay?
So here's a question that I wanna ask.
I'm gonna ask Porter and Aaron,
cause I'm sure that somebody is gonna ask this
or thinking this.
Aaron, you go to an area, everything looks good,
juicy area, good lead flow, low competition,
and there's only like, let's say three, four people
that are paying for ads,
paying for some kind of lead generation.
What do you do?
If I only see three or four people that are paying for leads,
I would not go into that area.
Porter, what about you?
The reason being-
Oh, finished, finished, finished.
Oh yeah, no, I get it.
So this is especially if you're starting out,
like if you're not at 10K and I'm not at 10K,
if you're not at 10K,
these are not deals you should be pushing.
Yeah, for sure.
Like if you've got the sales experience,
you got the conviction,
you got the, like your systems are just dialed in,
yeah, you could be, you might get that work,
but that'd be like a higher skill deal to land.
And again, you could land it,
but you'll most likely get a better bang for your buck
just going with an area of more people to prospect.
Facts, yep.
There's nothing worse than finally getting leads
and then just not having prospects anymore.
It's rare, but it happens and it sucks.
100%, 100%.
Porter?
I think a lot of times if the metrics look good,
I think all of us are like, dude, I don't care.
Like there's gotta be a business owner.
Like we all kind of jump on that city that looks good.
So like if you do,
there's probably some of you that are doing this right now,
like go check and see if people are running ads.
And if that is the case, I mean,
you know your Google ads are your number one,
your home advisor and your energy list
is probably your two and three.
And then anything after that,
like you could dip into your Facebook groups,
which I'm telling you,
you're scraping the barrel.
Like I've done that before and it's not worth it
because I just lost two deals and that's exactly what I did.
But if you're not doing that,
you could also go to neighboring cities.
If you're in a suburb area,
you could go to a neighboring city that's close to it
and search it.
And maybe there's people running ads like 20 minutes away,
which people love to travel if they got the work.
But again, with Aaron,
I think if you want to start off right,
you don't necessarily want to target those areas.
But again, I'm guilty of it.
I still go into those areas sometimes
because I'm like, dude, this is a golden area.
This looks good.
There's gotta be someone that wants the leads.
I would say if you,
I think that's a really good nuance that Aaron pointed out.
And I agree with what Porter saying as well,
that if you are not at least at a couple of deals,
I'd say five, 10K, make it easy on yourself.
Make sure there's five,
I'd say maybe seven to 10 business owners
that are paying for some form of advertising,
whether it's, you know, ideally Google ads,
then we go with HomeAdvisor, Andy's List, et cetera.
Now, when, you know, after you've closed a bunch of deals,
you're at 20K, 30K, 40K, there were areas,
there was like two people that were paying for ads.
I was going into that area because I knew my pitch so well.
I had so much momentum.
I had so many examples of, and better yet,
it was like, I had franchised,
people in franchises that were the same.
Like I knew I was gonna get the deal,
but I was in that niche.
I was the expert in that niche.
And so it's a little bit different.
So if you guys are brand new, make it easy on yourself.
Go into an area that has as many business owners
as possible paying for some form of ads.
Now, one more thing I wanna cover
before we get into some of the Q&A stuff is,
one, like for me, any form of paying for leads
is better than none, but Google ads,
the reason I like Google ads people the best
is because they're usually spending the most money.
And this is a question I hear people ask all the time.
Well, why would they spend money with you
when they're already paying for Google ads?
Okay?
Aaron smiling because he can literally speak just like me.
Aaron, I know you're gonna say the perfect answer.
Why is that?
Why would they still spend money with you?
There's a couple of reasons.
One is it's better to have two fishing poles
on the pond than one,
because you're gonna catch more fish.
Number two, just because they're getting clicks
doesn't mean they're getting leads.
They could be targeting,
they have all their targeting settings off
for what they want.
They could have a landing page that doesn't convert,
let alone, even if those things are true,
again, what we're doing is if the ROI is still good,
yeah, maybe their ROI isn't as high
as if they get it from their own marketing source
that they manage themselves,
but it still makes sense if they make money from.
So yeah, I used to think that too though.
It's a fair question, but that's,
if you guys are thinking that you're assuming
that just because someone is running ads,
you think they're getting leads.
Google ads is to get clicks, not leads,
that you pay for clicks, not for leads.
The one advantage Home Advisor has
is you're paying for leads, not clicks,
except for you gotta share them.
Guys, can't you see how much better of a service it is
that we offer?
Like it's, we're taking the good part of Home Advisor,
we're taking the good part of Google,
and we're giving both to them.
It's exclusive because that's kind of what Google does,
and it's leads, which is what Home Advisor does.
And it's, they don't have to share it.
I don't know, sometimes you have to go
and you have to like put yourself in the shoes
of the business owner and think about,
imagine paying for Home Advisor.
Imagine as an agency owner,
you're paying Home Advisor for leads, right?
And they send you a lead,
and that lead is getting,
they're sending that same lead to five other agencies,
right?
And guess what?
One of these clients are looking for it,
most likely is the cheapest price.
And you're like, dude, I don't want to compete on price.
It's not worth it for me.
And then somebody else calls you and they're like,
yo, I'm gonna send you these jobs.
You're the only one I'm gonna send them to,
that's your job to, like it's yours to lose,
and I'm only gonna work with you.
Dude, it's an easy sell.
It's a very easy sell.
So anyway, that's the biggest points I wanna cover.
Guys, make it easy on yourself.
The easier you make it on yourself,
the more likely you're gonna be to actually,
you know, just get the deal.
And again, I know when you're starting out,
it's easy to wanna jump into that first deal,
find that first city and get started.
And I love that energy.
I love that energy.
But guys, now that we have freaking rank and run engine
where you can do a due diligence in like 13 seconds,
you guys should be tearing through areas.
You should be picking a niche
and you should be picking a hundred cities
and you should do the first 50 yourself,
create a process, get an outsourcer from, you know,
onlinejobs.ph and you should be cranking
a hundred due diligence a day to find that city.
And I would rather go a week to find the best city
and, you know, maybe it takes you three extra days
than what you were gonna do
if you would have went with that okay city.
Cause if you guys can find that right city and niche,
dude, it makes every freaking thing easier
and it's exciting, it's fun.
So anyway, I can't stress enough about due diligence.
And I think sometimes we're like,
oh, I'm doing something wrong.
But as Porter said in the beginning,
most likely you're just talking to the wrong people.
You could say the right thing to the wrong person
and it's not gonna land.
Makes sense?
So true.
And you can say the wrong things to the right person
and it might still work.
That's the truth.
So I swear it's more about the person.
So finding those right areas, number one,
talking to the right people.
And then I guess the last thing
that we can talk about really quick is don't be so excited
and salesy when someone says yes,
be a little hesitant, pull back a little bit,
be willing to lose the deal.
If it feels a little off, be willing to say,
hey, whoa, whoa, just so I can check
before I send you this lead,
but by the way is digital gold.
I just wanna make sure you're hungry to grow here, sir.
Cause I can only work with one company per area.
I've had quite a bit of interest here in Tucson.
And before I dedicate and kind of like marry myself to you,
like, can you just give me a little bit of a feedback
as to why, how I'm convinced me
that you're serious about growing.
Cause I don't wanna waste my time either.
I'm running a business just like you, right?
Don't be afraid.
People are so afraid that if they say that,
they're gonna lose the deal.
All that's gonna do is help you get the deal.
It's gonna build trust
because you're not so freaking desperate to get that deal.
So anyway, let's go into a little bit of Q and A.
We can kind of mix in some other stuff
that comes to our minds as we go.
But guys, who you talk to is more important
than what you say.
I promise you that.
If you are talking to the right person that's hungry,
you can mess up a lot of the other stuff.
You're still gonna get the deal.
On the contrary, you go pick some random Joe off the street
that's in a Facebook group
that's not willing to spend 10 cents.
You could say all the right things.
The money's just not there or the mindset's just not there.
It's just not gonna work.
It is so important you're talking to the right people.
And so that's why we stress so much.
Go and sell.
That's why the module is called Selling to the Already Sold.
Building your list.
Do we have any questions so far, Aaron?
So we don't have any specific questions,
but one good comment from Brad Hardy.
This was in reference to the question
of why would a business wanna pay me
if they're already paying for Google Ads themselves.
But he said, they're busy doing the work.
They aren't watching the ads.
At all.
Bingo, like if we just zoom out,
sometimes we as marketers start a full-time job.
Sometimes we're not as focused on particular projects
or ad campaigns as we need to be.
So I don't know who doesn't know what we're doing.
So probably doesn't even wanna do it anyway
because they're like, they got that mental friction of like,
ah, I don't even know what I'm doing.
Why do you even bother?
So yeah.
Yep.
I completely agree with that.
You guys think for one second,
I mean, these people are worried about everything
from their cell phone bill to their company t-shirt,
to their insurance, to the gas.
What they did is they went to a conference,
they heard their buddy.
If they were lucky, they hired their niece
who's taking a marketing class in college,
marketing 101, learning from a professor
that makes like 40 grand a year, that's never done ads.
And that's who's running their ads.
So be a little persistent, guys.
By the way, you said there was a question
on the original post, Aaron?
Did we already answer that?
No, that was Heather's comment talking about,
she's glad this was the topic
because this is one of her main roadblocks.
Now with that, I would say,
and we can probably talk about this a bit as well,
is, and if you guys have questions,
you can drop them in the comments.
With qualifying, it seems like there's three times,
like three different stages in the sales process
where people fall off, like usually,
and this is usually because either we messed up
with our sales pitch or approach,
or because they were just a bad prospect to begin with.
And that's usually one of those two reasons.
And by the way, when in doubt, blame yourself,
just little advice for life.
But anyway, I was gonna say that,
it looks like she said that particularly,
she's struggling with, she'll cold call them,
she'll get a yes, but then they fall off
after she sends a few leads.
So it gets ghosted before the Zoom call.
That's like stage one of bad qualifying,
like second stage, it seems like,
would be where you hop on the Zoom close,
and then there's just something that they throw at,
that's just clearly they're not a good fit.
So I was talking with an illegal immigrant
on a close call at one point,
didn't really work out one of those things,
that bad qualifying job.
And then finally, number three would be like,
as you were talking to me about,
is if they're, you got the deal,
but they're just not handling the leads well,
because they don't, and then they just,
they fall off because of that, if that kind of makes sense.
So like before the call, during the call,
and then after the sale.
100%.
Let's talk about when you're getting ghosted,
because I know this is a pretty like,
okay, so you build the list properly, boom,
there's seven to 10 people, you got your pitch dialed in,
you get the deal hooked, and let's just say,
let's talk with, let me ask Porter first.
So Porter, you get them, they're excited,
yeah, sounds good, send me a couple of leads,
boom, you hang up the phone, and first scenario,
first circumstance is,
they never answer the phone again after that, right?
You haven't sent them any leads,
they're just kind of ghost after that.
What do you learn from that, what can we,
what can you do, and what can you learn from that?
If you get somebody hooked,
and then they never answer the phone,
you never send them a lead, you try to send them a lead,
but they just ghost.
This happened a lot when I first started out,
and I do, and I don't know if this is 100% the reason why,
but I felt like I was saying too much on the first call.
I was, you could always add more information to them,
but you can never take away.
So as soon as you start talking about SEO, backlinking,
you being able to rank these websites,
these guys are like, what the crap did you just say?
And then they get all weirded out by it.
So I felt like I was saying too much to the point where
I was trying to sell them on the first call,
and so I stopped doing that.
I stick exactly to the script, I do the bare minimum,
and then I can always add onto that.
But if someone was to ghost me,
I mean, that's where the pullback,
you have to be like, dude, it's okay,
I have the fear of no loss, whatever,
give them the pullback, say, hey, Mr. Business Owner,
I understand you're busy,
but I am trying to run a business as well.
If you're interested in these leads,
message me back by the end of the day, if not,
I will start sending these to somebody else, thanks.
Something along those lines,
and if they are interested, they will come back,
and if they're not, then just move on.
I wouldn't even be emotional about it.
100%.
In the training, we talk about this again.
Sorry to keep going back to the training,
but I'm gonna go back to the training, right?
Which is, you remember the example I used, guys,
we're selling a date or dinner, not marriage, right?
We're not going in, frickin' first time meeting a chick,
and then we're like talking about marriage.
That's when people get weird, dude.
They're like, yo, I'm never talking to this guy again,
right, that's weird.
Unless it's your boy, I'm closing that thing first date.
Everybody else cannot do that, okay?
No, I'm just kidding.
So I saw this happen in door-to-door sales.
Porter had a good point.
I would see this happen with new reps all the time.
Can you guys still hear me, by the way?
I was a little choppy, I'm sorry.
Good?
All right, so new reps, when they first started,
including me, we'd give them a pitch,
and it was a four-step pitch.
Who you are, why you're there, the deal,
and the transition, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, okay?
And every time you teach them the simple pitch,
they do it, they get in the house,
they get their first deal, maybe five deals,
and then all of a sudden they'd stop closing,
they'd go into slump fest, okay?
And every single time you would go with these reps,
you would find out they were just vomiting information
on the door, right?
They were jumping ahead and skipping steps.
And I like what Porter said, he's like,
you can always give them more, you can't take it away,
and there's a quote that says something like,
the man that doesn't talk can never be misquoted.
Just in sales, sometimes more is less and less is more.
Be very succinct about what you have to say,
but don't over-talk.
They start asking you questions.
This is common, right?
We get our first couple of deals,
and then the business owner's like,
dude, but just tell me,
how much are we looking right now?
And you're like, well, and you just drop price, right?
There's a reason we do it in the order that we do it,
or they'll say, so yeah, dude,
I'm happy to do 10% split.
And instead of you going,
hey, let's not worry about that right now,
and explaining it on the screencast,
and at the end, you're like,
nope, the only thing that I do is flat fee.
And then all of a sudden,
the business owner doesn't understand
why the flat fees make sense,
and all they're gonna do is just ghost you.
So do not freaking skip steps.
Keep it simple.
Less is more, more is less.
Talk to the right business owners.
You just guide them through the process, okay?
Also, let's talk about the second situation, Aaron.
We hook a business owner.
We, you know, sounds good to get a couple of leads.
You send them two, three leads.
This one's the most painful.
You send them two to three leads, and then they ghost you.
What can we learn from that?
What do you do in that situation?
Yeah, it seems like when that happens,
it's gonna either come down to
they were innately not a good fit,
or again, you messed up somewhere along the process.
And I'm gonna be honest,
it is really hard to tell sometimes with those situations,
because then you're thinking like,
well, did I say something?
Should I have said something else?
There's just a lot of variables at play.
And usually, obviously, you first wanna look at yourself
and, okay, did I say too much?
As you talk about your new reps, your sales guys,
like they're probably giving too much information.
So it could have been on your end.
And if you can't find anything,
then you can kind of begin to think,
okay, well, is this business owner just not a good fit?
But, and sometimes it seems like there are businesses
that have just been burned so bad
by other marketing companies
that they're just completely closed off.
It makes it kind of weird
that they would take a couple of leads,
but some just don't trust you.
Nothing you do can make them trust you,
even sometimes when giving free leads,
it almost seems like,
where they just don't believe it.
And again, that might be where you might need
to be a bit more persuasive in your approach, perhaps,
but that one's a bit more dicey.
Yeah.
And that's where the only thing you can do
in a situation like that,
if you're literally getting ghosted,
is you have to just take control back.
You have to take the deal off the table
and you have to have some huevos
and you have to send the text.
You have to send the text.
That's it.
So, and we've talked about length.
I'm sure there's three different lives we've had
inside this group on the pullback, right?
The breakup text, that thing is money.
It's a little bit scary in the beginning.
And it's always like, you're, you know,
and the best part is when sometimes you send
the breakup text and the business owner
tries to make you feel bad, like, well, I'm not,
you lost me at that.
You lost me.
And it's like, bro, shut up.
You guys have had this, right?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I've never done that.
And even if they did, those are the type of people
that cancel after week three
because the leads were slow that week.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
Guys, I'm at a point in my life and in business especially,
but if there's a relationship,
whether it's a business relationship, a friendship,
whatever, and people get like,
if I can tell they're gonna be difficult
and high maintenance, and it's gonna take me a lot to make,
like, I meet a new friend and it's like,
they get offended easy, dude.
It's not my friend, bro.
Like, I just don't have the energy.
If I meet a business owner,
I don't care what you're willing to give me.
I used to be the guy, and maybe you guys wanna do this.
I used to call, I would call it an a-hole tax.
So I would be like, okay,
this person's gonna be a difficult,
they're gonna kind of be an a-hole.
I'm gonna charge them extra.
And if they do it, I'll still work with them.
And I would put up with quite a bit
because I wanted the money.
And even now, I just won't do that, dude.
If somebody's difficult with, like, I just won't.
Like, we've had, we've had students, dude.
We've had students that, like, we can just tell,
and we're like, yeah, it's not worth it.
Go your merry way, you're not worth anything.
And it's just, no amount of money is worth it.
So keep that in mind, guys,
is if somebody's difficult in the beginning,
they're probably gonna be difficult throughout.
And depending on what you're,
like, you'll get what you tolerate.
And I won't tolerate much at this point, right?
I know what I'm worth.
I know I'm valuable.
And my tolerance has gone completely down.
It's very low.
I have a very low tolerance for a bunch of weird people
that I'm just not interested in talking to.
So just be choosy, dude.
It's your business, it's your clients.
You get to choose who you work with.
You get to choose the price.
You get to choose how you do business.
You get to, it's literally how you build it
and what you're willing to tolerate and accept.
And that's the beautiful thing about it, okay?
So biggest takeaway I'm gonna say from qualifying
is it's most likely an issue with who you're talking to,
not an issue with what you're saying.
In sales, most of the time,
if you're losing someone at a certain step,
it's the step before, right?
If you're losing them when you're trying to get,
when you're cold calling, trying to do the hook
and you're not hooking anyone,
usually because you're talking to the wrong people, right?
If you're losing them, when you're sending them leads,
usually when you did the hook, you oversold it,
you said too much, whatever, you freaked them out.
It's usually the one or two steps before.
So you're not closing the deal,
you usually didn't do the setup correctly, right?
Which by the way, starts from the moment you call
to the moment that you close the deal.
Any other comments, any other questions that people have?
Yeah, we got some comments that started rolling.
And so real quick, this is just, we can address this.
Corey Gilbert said, if I got 80 clicks and only five leads,
is that a good ratio?
I think that's 16%.
I was trying to do the calculation while you're talking.
So 16% like click to lead ratio.
I think that sounds pretty good to me,
depending on the niche, I guess, right?
If it's plumbing, it's probably pretty bad.
If it's basement waterproofing,
that's a good conversion right there.
Okay, so let's see.
Corey made the comment,
I don't see how rare is faster with DD.
So Corey, I don't know if you've like ever done
a market research like template on your own,
like Google Sheets, like kind of in the original training,
but it takes a long while to go over the individual backlinks
and everything,
because you're able to just put in one thing.
Yeah, I don't-
You should go try, what you should do is go to,
I think in the training,
we talk about like how to do the due diligence
with the sheet.
Go and open up a Google Sheet
and go and copy and paste everything in.
Look at the backlinks,
go and find the age of the domain.
Get a White Spark account and get a-
Get a White Spark, go do all of that.
Yeah, go time it.
It's way faster.
It's probably four or five times faster
to do it on due diligence.
You're probably comparing,
I think you're just comparing that to,
I don't think there's any other comparison.
Go try and do it manually.
And by the way,
for those of you that don't want to use Rankin Energy,
you don't have to use it by all means.
I did my first, not thousand,
but probably my first hundred due diligence,
not even using the template.
I used to print the pages off
and I would write them physically out.
And I had this stack of due diligence
and I would sit there and I would spend
three, four hours sometimes in a day,
just looking at cities, just clicking through cities,
copy and paste and clearing my browser history.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
Okay, yep, yep, yep.
And the other problem with that guys is you're human
so you're not going to see as much stuff.
You might read it wrong,
like all these different variables.
You don't have to use that tool.
But what I was saying with my point being
with using Rankin Engine is that
if I could save even five minutes
and I'm doing 20 due diligence,
dude, I mean, I just saved myself what?
Over an hour, almost two hours,
hour and 40 minutes.
Like that's insane, right?
And I know you're saving 15 minutes per due diligence.
So anyway, sometimes there's no context.
Go do one manually.
But even if you don't want to,
then just use the regular sheet.
The point is you got to put in the reps.
And the reason I know how to look at a good area
is because I've literally done over a thousand myself.
So I know when an area, even if it looks good,
oh, that thing's off.
This looks like that one time that I tried it.
And then, so as much as I want to train
and as much I want to show you,
it does take you doing reps to figure it out.
But great question, Cory.
Yeah, and for the record,
the reason it took Nick four years to scale
was because he was doing his due diligence on paper
in the 21st century.
Just throwing that out there.
All right.
That's just a small example of a much larger problem.
I was doing everything in my business.
Old school, slow, I'm doing it myself.
I'm writing my own content.
Like I was not going to let go of sales.
I didn't know how to scale.
And finally in 2020, I was like, okay, let's go.
But yeah, good point.
That's right.
So Jason, great question.
Will there be a module
where we can look over your shoulder
doing due diligence in R&R engine?
We aren't rank and rent engine.
We are working on redoing the due diligence training.
Of course.
And by the way, we are going to be using
the rank and rent engine tool
with the new training as the go-to tool.
Because I know in our original one,
I used a couple of different tools
and I kind of said use whatever.
It's easier if I can just use one.
In this one, we have control over.
We trust at least to a certain extent
because we can only trust Google's data they give us.
But yes, that's going to be part of it for sure.
So just as a heads up,
we might have something even released
a little sooner than that.
Kind of give you guys some snippets.
You have to wait for everything to come out.
But yes, that's a really good question.
Jason, all red?
No, that was Jason Adam.
Okay, great.
What's up, Jason?
Yeah.
That's right.
So real quick, let me see this question.
Okay, yeah.
Joe says, hey guys, new to the group.
So Joe, let me get back to you that in just a second.
I'm going to try to answer any qualifying questions
that a lot of people are having
rank and run engine questions.
Let me see.
Also, real quick, there's a, what's the code?
Somebody had a couple of people message me.
Can you, can someone post the chat?
The code for the discount is capital land.
It's all caps landlord 24.
Okay.
You want to drive that?
You can put that in there.
I'm looking through the comments.
Porter, can you put that in?
Yep.
All caps.
This for digital landlord students.
Correct.
Landlord, all caps, landlord, one word, 24, no spaces.
That's for, I think 20% off for the first two months.
Again, guys, use whatever you want to use.
You don't have to use anything.
If you can get around and you can plug this and plug that,
you don't have to.
We're just trying to make this
as easy as possible for you guys.
And for me, if I can go and I can save two hours a day,
look at 20 more due diligence,
maybe find one or two extra good cities,
that one or two cities every day times five days
times fourth weeks, times 12 months.
Dude, I'm light years ahead.
But sometimes when you start,
you're just thinking about, you know, whatever.
You're thinking about, I'm going to do this manually,
which is fine.
Go do it manually and then you'll appreciate it later.
So, but yeah, landlord 24 is the code.
What other questions?
Yeah.
So Julia has a really good question.
Says, what are the main questions you asked
during prospecting, live transfers and following up?
If you guys already answered this, it's no problem.
I'll just rewatch the live.
We can address this specifically.
I did put in the comments
because I kind of anticipated this.
Fixit Felix, a while back, he made a post
and kind of just assembled a lot of the qualifying questions
slash green flags.
And then of course the opposite of those would be red flags.
He looks for one qualifying business center.
So I put that in the chat.
And Nick, I also texted it to you and Porter in Slack
if you guys want to look at that real quick.
But it kind of, these questions just,
we look at them to check off the main boxes.
And I kind of talked about this earlier,
but hungry to grow their business.
Not only that, kind of a nuance is hungry to grow,
like hungry for the specific leads in the specific area.
That's something that if you miss that,
that can turn out to be a bad fit.
If they have to travel 50 minutes
and you don't realize that for your tree trimming job,
you know, they're not gonna really be wanting to do that.
So a couple questions.
I'll let you answer these, Nick.
Okay, let's go rapid fire through the questions.
And real quick, let's, I love this green light
in qualifying questions that you put.
I think we can just copy and paste that
as like a parting little gift for everybody.
So let's just rapid fire these last few questions.
We'll drop that.
That's gonna be the green light, you know,
and also the qualifying questions
that you can, as like a takeaway.
And real quick, if I could ask you, Nick,
and I can give my quick 20 second opinion here.
It seems like there's a balance on the cold call.
If you ask too many probing questions,
it's easy to lose the deal and spook them.
And like, it's easy to lose.
But then on the same end,
you don't want to wait till you've sent four leads
before you start to ask some discovery questions.
So for me personally, it kind of seems like
after I send that first lead,
then I can kind of like,
I now earned the right to like investigate to some degree.
I don't know what your thoughts on that.
Or like, if you have discovery calls after the cold caller.
100%.
Dude, from the top, as soon as I get the deal,
if I feel confident enough to send them one lead
and I don't feel like they're shady
or trying to get a free lead, I'll send them the lead.
And then I'll call them back after they get the lead.
Like, hey, did you get that schedule?
Awesome.
Hey, I want to ask you really quick.
Like, yeah, you've earned the right to ask those questions.
And sometimes on that first call, I can tell,
hey, dude, I actually was talking to my partner.
This is something we're super interested in.
Yo, you're from Utah.
Like, they're just warm.
I'll feel comfortable to do that right there.
But a lot of times I do wait till the second call
as I'm building the trust
and earning the right to ask those questions.
Yes, exactly.
Sure, if you hear the chainsaw in the background,
now's not a good time to ask how many crews they have.
That's exactly.
All right.
That's exactly right.
Yeah, I just put that in the comments.
I'll do it one more time.
If, Nick, you want to just read through
those qualifying questions,
you can just kind of sprinkle these up
throughout the sales process.
Obviously, the earlier, the better without spooking up.
So I'm going to just read through
the qualifying questions right now.
Some that you could ask, you don't need to ask all.
And you certainly don't have to ask.
These are just some good ideas, okay?
Do you want more jobs, which is part of our script, right?
Hey, are you hungry to take on more jobs?
I'm guessing you're not allergic to money
and you're spending money on ads.
I'm assuming you want more jobs, okay?
Then you can also ask
if you will specifically want a certain type of job.
You can ask how long they've been in business.
That's indicative of like,
if they're maybe going to go belly up
or they have any money in the bank.
Oh, I just started last week.
I have a chainsaw and a truck.
That one could last two days or, you know,
those are rough.
I've worked with those people before.
They never pan out.
Making sure that they're licensed and insured.
That one you might want to bring up
a little bit down the road.
Cause if they're not, you might spook them.
Again-
If they have a green card at the minimum.
About a hundred percent.
Yeah, you got to make sure
they at least are legal in the country.
That's a given.
I don't know.
That one, I'm not sure we're going to include that
in the training or how to bring that one up,
but maybe we'll do that on a special section
if you're targeting certain states.
How many crews do you have?
And then how are you currently landing your jobs?
Are you getting them from Facebook?
Is it referral?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And another question I might ask is,
you know, I would ask this at some point,
but you could also ask us on the opening calls,
like, dude, it sounds like you know what you're doing.
Like what?
You probably have a pretty high close percentage, right?
How many deals are you closing out of the,
out of the leads you're getting?
Or are you closing what percentage?
And they're usually going to be like, oh, like 90%.
And it's like, well, that's cause you get all your jobs
from referrals.
So they're already sold, bro.
It should be a hundred percent.
So actually anything below a hundred means
you're sub-optimal human and you suck.
But good job.
Here's, should I go over the green lights really quick,
Aaron, to wrap this up?
Yeah.
And obviously the opposite of these would be red flags.
100%.
Here's some green lights.
If they're hungry to grow,
if they're hungry for specific leads
in your specific location,
if they have bandwidth to grow,
if they can actually handle more jobs,
if they've been in business for at least a couple of years
and that they're licensed to ensure,
these are a couple of green flags.
Anything opposite of this is going to be red flags as well.
But guys, I guess as my final thought,
you can have all the answers.
You can have everything dialed out in front of you,
but until you just start making calls,
you're not going to know what the heck we're talking about.
It's not going to make sense.
It's not going to be relatable.
You got to pick up the phone.
You got to make the mistakes.
You're going to have to call and say too much
and bomb it on a business owner verbally
until you lose the deal on the perfect business owner
that was going to pay you all this money.
And you said too much, you lost the deal.
I mean, Porter has lost like $3,000 a month
in retainers over the last like six hours, dude,
or six days.
I mean, Porter's just giving away.
Just throw it.
Just give it.
No, I'm just kidding.
But you have to lose these deals, guys.
I've lost deals saying some of the most silliest stuff,
embarrassing stuff.
I mean, it's just dumb stunts.
And this is including alarms.
Like I've lost thousands and tens of thousands of dollars
just saying and doing the wrong stuff.
And it took those deals that I lost
to get to where I am now.
And so I looked at it as like a debt
that I was paying towards learning how to do this.
So I think no matter what we said here, guys,
if you're not doing calls, if you're not making calls,
none of this matters.
Step one, make calls.
Step two, figure out where you're going wrong.
Take the information we shared today and start refining.
Become obsessed with your craft.
Become obsessed and dial them.
Because if you can get 5%, 10%, 15% better at this,
again, the people that make the most money in this business
are not the geeks, not the tech, not the this, that,
the rest, Mr. Backlink.
They're the people that know how to get business owners
to give them their credit card.
They don't even have the best product.
They don't even give their business owners the most leads.
They're not even the best at retaining them.
They are the best at getting business owners
to give them their money.
And so you don't have to be in sales
or have a sales experience to start,
but it is in your best interest
to start obsessing over this skill
and at least do it until you get to a certain revenue level.
And then sure, go ahead and outsource it.
Find somebody to do it if you really, really hate it.
But this is a skillset that has the highest return
of any skillset in this business.
And it is called sales,
and it is taking candy from little children.
I'm just kidding.
All right, anything else?
Any other questions?
There was a couple of questions on rank and rent engine one,
but I don't know if, is there a live,
like when I'm trying to think of something we can,
something we can point them to
if they have more questions about that.
I'll text Ryan right now
and see if he wants to go live in the group
and kind of ask those questions.
If you wanna screenshot those and send me a text after,
let's separate those,
so that would make a really good live.
I think there's probably gonna be a bunch of questions
that have come up sitting out that people are using it
and whatever, but that's a great point.
Will you text me?
Yes.
Okay, guys, if you-
So guys, we're gonna address those questions.
Yeah, so those aren't gonna get ignored.
Yeah, no, for sure.
In fact, let me just text him
so no one thinks I'm making that up.
Hey, I'm on the call,
the live right now.
We have some people that have questions
about rank and run engine.
Anyway, rank and run engine.
I'm gonna say wanna go live-
We have one more qualified question
we can ask after this.
Okay.
Okay, go ahead.
Awesome.
So Mike Price says,
what do you guys think about selling to the top,
like one to five organically ranked companies in the city,
people who have probably invested in SEO at some point?
As long as they're running ads, dude, I don't care.
I got a business owner right now in one of my areas
that is ranked on Google.
They're also paying another company to do what I'm doing.
I think that they might just be paying them to do SEO
and they are buying leads.
So as long as they're running ads,
they're still hungry to grow, dude.
If they're not, I don't really see that,
I'm probably not gonna target them.
That I do like, if I don't have any,
if they're not paying for ads,
can't find anyone in the Facebook group,
the fact that I can tell they've done SEO
at least lets me know they spent some money
on their market.
They paid somebody to build their website.
That's at least a start,
but I'd probably try to target somebody
like on the bottom of page one, top of page two,
where I can tell their page title is done
by someone in those SEO.
They have an H1, you can kind of tell
if it's done professionally.
I wouldn't target somebody like that.
It's like, oh, they paid money,
but they're not getting the lead.
So, but if they're paying for ads,
I don't really care where they're ranked
because they want more business.
Most of the big companies, by the way,
that client that was paying me like 30 grand a month
at one point, all of the cities
that we were getting leads for them,
their website was ranked at the top three with us.
They were just hungry.
So it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Just go for it.
Sometimes you gotta stop overthinking too.
And it's a great question,
but I think sometimes the reason
that someone like me and Porter
and some of these guys are doing well
is we don't overthink
or we're too lazy to think or we can't think.
I don't know.
We're just like, oh, sweet.
Pick up the phone, call, give them a couple of leads,
build up a little website.
That sounds easy.
And that's why we do it.
And I'm telling you,
this is such a simple business model.
Don't ever complicate it.
That's it.
All right.
Thanks guys.
Appreciate it, Aaron.
I'm gonna upload this to our deal
and I'll see you soon.
I'll see you too on our team meeting.
Appreciate everyone being on.
We'll see you on next Tuesday at 7 a.m. MST.
If you're new, by the way,
welcome to your first call.
Much more to come.
And I just met, hold on.
Let me see if Ryan notices me back.
I just told him he can go live
anytime he wants this week.
Let me see.
Has not responded yet.
As soon as he does, we'll make an announcement.
Thanks guys.
Talk soon. See you guys.
Bye.